all right no need to panic just yet
we're going about it very calmly right
Bob
right right Bob just calmly going about
this hey hey hey hey hey hey hey it's
okay it's all right I'm a doctor
I know what's best the Medical Board
didn't like the way I treated the
patients before so this time I need to
be very careful in my excision of the
sternal cavity so let's take this
precision tool this expert precision saw
here and very delicate my watch watch
came off booth grabbed the lung and rip
it out of there no need for that nothing
for the other ones we're running out of
time though we need oh we need to hurry
up here we don't have much time it's
okay Bob it's okay I gotcha I gotcha I
gotcha
I can't lose Bob again
[Applause]
[Music]
okay alright try again take a second
model get on that it's okay I'm gonna be
okay because I'm a doctor I'm a praying
medical professional praying I'm praying
in his brain drilling his brain okay no
I can't relevant brain brain brain brain
for a sick man it's crazy
sure we need 32 cc's of Hydra more two
pairs own exercise my right top rate
directly into that into the brain and in
the brain you beat me in all those huh
what's going on I seem to be in a
medical theater wait what happened to
this patient who who did this to you who
did this to you
Hey I needed that
I need that what give me the damn thing
give it to me oh you gotta be kidding me
Oh
what